all right all
right sit down sit
down sit
down happy Wednesday everyone so if you
were going about your business yesterday
and suddenly felt the Earth shutter on
its axis it's not because Jerry Nadler
tipped over damn no it's that Congress
actually got something right in a
bipartisan vote the house of reps
censured Rashida
t okay censuring it's less effective
than putting CarX on a cold store but
we'll take it for even 22 Democrats to
Leb statements blaming Israel and
America for the 107 attacks while
calling the Hamas Massacre resistance
were simply too much Drew TB is so nutty
she's asked not to sit near people with
allergies now censuring doesn't really
amount to much it's the Congressional
equivalent of finding Hamas for
trespassing but it seems the Dems are
finally waking up to the out- ofc
control monsters they've created it's
probably how Steve Ducey felt when Peter
turned
12 here's how tb's fellow Squad monsters
try to defend
her what is true here is that every
single one of them has not acknowledged
the fact that Palestinians are dying in
the tens of thousands but we'll continue
to say it is us who are not
acknowledging Humanity elected body
enslave black people racism and sexism
islamophobia get pushed off of elevators
xenophobia and more right here in this
workplace maybe because of your lack of
diversity you lack the cognitive and
emotional ability to recognize diverse
opinions when they speak truth to power
whoa no wonder Trump wants to bring back
asylums I bet ilhan Omar's brother is so
glad she divorced him
but if they build those asylums they
better build them big because tens of
thousands of college kids now believe
anti-Semitism is something you get extra
credit for they prefer brutal
dictatorships one that counter their
novel pronouns with a noose so like
confused parents mainstream Dems are
scrambling to come up with a way to tell
their spoiled brat children behave or go
to your room so how do we get to a point
where young Dems think terrorists are
are the good guys while the state of
Israel the freest nation in the mid East
deserves to be destroyed well here's
some history that the Bratz never
learned when Israel became an
independent state in the 1940s
Progressive supported it coming out of
World War II the Holocaust and a history
of pilgrims it was Jews who were seen as
the oppressed and boy is that an
understatement to call 6 million people
exterminated oppressed it's like calling
me kind of
cute African-Americans recalled that
Jews had marched with them in civil
rights demonstrations Jews there had
been arrested and even killed too bad
Academia loves hiding facts like that
but then a strange thing happened Israel
committed the great unpardonable sin
much like me it was
successful and worse it looked a lot
like America while doing it and no one
hates success more than malicious
failures suddenly Israel was no longer a
safe haven for a people who had been
targeted throughout history it was no
longer the little country that could it
was an
oppressor nobody loves fighting the man
like a Democrat and it's all based in
Envy it's what progressives have instead
of actual progress you know we can't
build so let's tear down is their motto
so when America went to war in the mid
East after 911 you just knew sooner or
later the left would decide that we were
the bad guy which meant of course our
one true Ally in the midd East must be
one two it's the basic Progressive
formula America is a racist oppressor
and if you help it then you are too but
what about the millions of mostly black
and brown illegals pouring over our
Southern border right now guess they
must love racist oppression too but if
you spent your time burning down
buildings instead of going to class that
formula makes sense and when the left
gives the arsonist trophies it only
grows but the Full Tilt away from Israel
finally came with that OG Progressive
Barack Obama imagine looking at the midd
East and deciding the Iranians are the
good guys that's like having 600
channels and deciding on
CNN I know it was under Obama that
Iran's frozen assets return to the tune
of $150 billion let's see Iran funds
Hamas and Hezbollah and we give them 150
billion can you believe that didn't work
out what's farc for
dumbass Obama also gave 400 mil to the
Palestinian Authority money funnel to
their pay to slay program which rewards
families of so-called Martyrs I guess 72
virgins isn't enough of a cell and now
Obama undercuts Biden's own pro-israel
stance by saying nobody's hands are
clean wow did Barack eat a bad Bagel or
something or was it another
dog meanwhile kamla announced she'll
lead the fight against islamophobia
maybe she'll start a bail fund for Hamas
prisoners they probably don't need it
though the top three leaders of Hamas
are reportedly worth 11 billion while
their people live in squalor but really
this hate didn't spring up overnight
it's been simmering on campuses and the
media for years but with new Angry
radicals entering government the
screeching entitled chickens are now
coming home to roost so where does this
leave their party well if you're a
wild-eyed miscreant tearing down posters
of kidnapped kids and those are just
faculty members it puts you in the
driver's seat because while college is
all ideology and no experience in our
legislatures Nationwide the new left's
influence is growing like the hair on
Joy Bear's
back and so like groupies when I drop my
nipple ring in the pool it's a race to
the bottom
boring these kids aren't growing out of
it no five young pro Palestinian workers
at a Jewish owned coffee shop in
Manhattan just walked off the job over
the store's support for Israel the owner
even offered to take him to dinner to
talk things out but they quit instead
the store was on the verge of closing
but then members of the local Jewish
Community showed up in droves some even
volunteered to work shifts themselves so
talk about a contrast a closed Fist
versus a helping hand anyway it's no
wonder our cities are starting to look
like Gaza in that sense standing up to
this growing radicalism makes all of us
Israel it's a similar fight luckily here
it won't involve tanks and guns Just
votes I
hope let's
welcome tonight's
guest she's my fourth favorite Charlie
after Brown Sheen and Manson out kick
host Charlie
Arnolds he packs a deadlier punch than
Jim Jones retired MMA fighter CH
sonin she's like a paperclip wiy thin
and easy to lose in between seat
cushions New York Times best-selling
author and function's contributor
C and he likes these intros almost as
much as he likes me New York Times
best-selling author comedian and former
NWA Champion
C Charlie welcome to the show thank you
nice leather oh thank you yeah are we
starting to see a rift in the party
between the traditional Democrats and
their psychopath
Offspring maybe so uh but like you just
mentioned censuring someone it doesn't
really serve to do much of anything and
I still believe that to be the case uh
you just have to wonder though when you
think of the squad you think of Rashida
Talib what is her IQ I mean truly what
is her IQ it's got to be in the
negatives right because from beginning
until being censured thank you yes
uh she just has done everything wrong
and she said every opportunity to
correct herself and make it better for
example when she was being chased down
the hallway do you condone Hamas
beheading babies no response asked again
no response asked again no response just
just say no and get them off your back I
mean just just play the game right
you're a politician you know how to lie
you know how to play the game and then
from there it just got even worse I mean
from the river to the Sea tweeting that
out getting all of the flak and still
saying nothing not taking it down not
saying I'm sorry it's just the whole
time it it makes no sense to me and
Corey Bush and her other friend ilon
Omar same thing I mean did you watch
Cory Bush's ranting and raging yes of
course watch it on mute it's even better
you know uh the body language you're
saying body language was better than the
word you gave a an eloquent evidence
that she's indeed stupid yes very much J
welcome to the show well thank you very
much so happy to have you here good to
be
here so you've been following this story
as closely as we have what are your
thoughts on this topic well I love the
way that you set it up because you you
made it sound as though a Democrat
versus a liberal and I haven't seen a
democrat in a long time and in all
fairness I was happy to see they still
existed was it 22 of them stood up and
pushed back I mean I really didn't think
that was good news I will tell you this
uh I I watched uh Tulsi get basically
eliminated in 2016 because Hillary
implied that she was a Russian spy and I
can't help but wonder what if she was
actually Russian and what if she lived
there and had Russian kids and went to
schools and she got elected and then
gets put out to Washington DC and then
goes with the Russians I mean I I just
have to wonder sometimes you're here to
defend your district and sometimes
you're here to defend your country our
country is steep forward to say who the
good guys are and who the bad guys are
that's it or you're not a patriot that
is the litmus test and she's failing it
that's a great point because she's like
um you think that she had competing
interests with our country but she
doesn't the country doesn't even factor
in right she has a sole interest yes
crazy cat crazy easy what did you think
about the censuring was it is it I'm so
happy that I learned to pronounce it you
know that I keep saying it censuring cuz
on the five I said censoring yeah it was
embarrassing I felt
humiliated you don't get embarrassed
Congress uh yeah I I don't I mean look
okay I condemn Hamas okay it's not to me
that's not hard to say I also the S I
feel like the Congress got a little
censure happy it's this tit fortat thing
based on part of iens ship or political
points where it's like okay these people
are supposed to work for us and actually
do things and so much of their jobs just
like ah got them right censure and for
me obviously you can't do anything more
than that because what she said is
constitutionally protected speech which
is a good thing it's a great thing that
we have the first amendment in this
country I thank you for the First
Amendment yeah let's go obviously we
have a pramas audience but I I think
that you know if you don't like the
statement use your own speech to say
that you don't like this statement
because I think more information is
better if this is how she feels and she
says it now we know how she feels I
think it's better to have that
information as Dana pointed out to me in
the break censuring is also a form of
speech sure but I if if we get to a
place where that's all they're doing
every day and still considering
themselves to be like oh look at how
great all they're doing is just well
yeah yeah ya ya do something that means
you're not spending your money yeah well
I mean they could when will they ever
will they ever cut something yes one day
they'll cut something I think they will
what do you think Tyrus what about the
fact that these guys are living 11
billion dollar do you think the
protesters on the street know how
wealthy Hamas leaders are yeah because
I'm sure they're doing Tik toks of their
workouts and their their indentured
wives and their parties in the hotels I
think was they saying at the Four
Seasons or something they're just living
their best lives getting their workouts
in uh all their bodyguards are
overweight so you got to good shot of
getting them if you find out where
they're at just like to point that out
but Charlie made a good point C made a
good Point made a good point but we're
missing the point M the reason why you
don't say I condemn something is when
you don't MH and to the point where any
man in here who's Ever Had a Wife forc
him to apologize and all he has to do at
dinner is say I'm sorry and you can have
lemon rang pie and go on with your
evening we will sit there and be
like sorry kids Dad's going down with
this one yeah no and the whole night
is because you believed in something so
strongly that you did not want to put
the toilet seat down anymore okay I put
it up you can put it down you're willing
to die for that
argument she does not have a problem
with Hamas M they don't have a problem
with Hamas did and we keep making this
mistake like well maybe they don't
understand maybe her IQ no this is who
she is when you want to see who the
progressives are and what they're about
this is it they're not going to change
MH because if you really cared about the
people of the pal Ians if you cared
about them you be like I condemn Hamas
for their actions has caused this how do
we work with Israel to get these people
out Hamas needs to go no when she talks
about them it's a blanket statement so
censor is not good enough because if you
go back during the Civil War there was
six I believe 16 Senators that refused
to acknowledge and they were expelled
they were put out they said the same
type of rhetoric you can say whatever
you want but we need to remember that
there's consequences for what you say
what she's saying is she was fine with
babies being murdered she had no issue
with that because it was on her team mhm
that's what it is we need to stop trying
to figure this out just listen to them
listen to them they are not hiding it
they're not speaking in code they are
believe them yeah like they're just who
they are all
right but and Tyrus it's the opposite of
leadership right she lives in a district
where this is what's popular to get
elected but if what's popular to get
elected isn't right you're the that
needs to stand back and T but it's not
what we're doing here it's not just for
the good of the when you look left and
right it's for our entire nation that's
the role that I'm in not lead the
problem with that's why you need term
limits because politicians Run for the
next election they don't do they just
get in they smile it solve a lot of
problems and then yeah would it would
all right we must move on up next they
want to slash the pay of the secretary
who's gay who wrote
that if you'll be in the New York area
and like tickets to see Gutfeld go to
foxnews.com / gutf and click on the link
to join our studio audience hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else